[Music]
he demands compliance
because he's science grouchy fauci is
firing back at critics who've been
hammering him
for flip-flopping on masks as well as
his early dismissal of the wuhan
lab leak theory still don't know how to
pronounce that because no one wants to
spread bad news about their friends
his point he had to change his position
as they learned more about the virus
at the time that we were saying we
shouldn't be wearing a mass there were
three factors that were going on
a there was a thought to be a shortage
of masks
b there was no evidence that masks
worked outside
of the context of a hospital thirdly we
were not aware
of the extent of asymptomatic spread it
wasn't only
me i'm picked out of the villain it was
the surgeon general of the united states
and the entire cdc ah and factor four
always passed the buck
but professor know it all didn't stop
there
all of the things that i have spoken
about consistently from the very
beginning
have been fundamentally based on science
sometimes those things were inconvenient
truths
for people and there was pushback
against me
so if you are trying to do you know get
at
me as a public health official and a
scientist
you're really attacking not only dr
anthony fauci you're attacking science
can't you see he's the real victim but
it is a great
strategy remember when you're attacking
greg gutfeld you're attacking
handsomeness
not that funny could happen anyway fauci
went on to reiterate his belief that the
virus
was of natural origin which uh senator
john kennedy later took issue with here
he is appearing on the very mysterious
program known as
hannity dr faucia needs to cut the crap
this isn't about dr fauci it's not about
his feelings and i'm sorry if his
feelings were hurt
you know maybe he ought to buy an
emotional support pony
since day one dr fauci and his uh
expert friends uh have told us look
the virus occurred naturally it jumped
from a bat to
through an intermediate host into human
beings
well it's been a year where's the proof
where's the smoking bat
it's a great question where is the
smoking bat i'm picturing a
lonely bat sitting at a bar smoking a
cigarette perhaps vaping because that's
what the bats do these days i can't keep
up with the bats
clay what are your thoughts on fauci he
would have been much better
off if he had disappeared and
resigned at 78 years old or whatever he
is last year
maybe when donald trump got lost the
election and he had a new president
coming in
because i think what's going to happen
is as we continue to investigate what
happened
how this i think escaped the laboratory
fauchi the fact that they were doing the
advanced function research the fact that
it was tax dollars involved
i think all of the emails and everything
else is going to lead back to
him ultimately being the fall man
for this entire theory and if he had
left when we changed the election
then i think he would have been in much
better shape this is only going to get
worse
and he could have made his book all
about working with trump and that would
have sold so much
more than what he's going to do now john
i remember on one of your podcasts you
uh you had this woman on who had done
like a poem
about the lockdown and stuff and it's
like the effect really
on kids and and everything in in this
whole phase of all of these restrictions
what are your thoughts on this you do
you give valchi some credit or no credit
you know i it's tough because i didn't
listen to anything he said
at any point in time
[Laughter]
you know i'm thinking like well yeah i
assumed that everything you said
wasn't true anyway so i did the opposite
yeah um but no the whole thing about
kids like you know um
i i think back to thinking when i was
eight or nine years old and what would
have happened to my parents
if i missed a season of sport i don't
know
if we would have got through it right i
think they would have probably sent me
somewhere and i
never came back
it's just you know yeah the whole
thing's been crazy but like i said i
just assumed that he was
you know pulling the wool on their eyes
or over eyes from the beginning yeah you
know it's uh
we've learned a lot in this pandemic or
at least i have i don't know about you
god knows if you have any memory of this
but
at the time it was good but i think we
were learning that experts are not
really experts no they're uh they
they're they're flying by the seat of
their pants just like everybody else you
know how like under trump he wasn't
allowed to talk i actually thought he
was very credible at that time
and now that biden's in office he's
talking all the time and i'm like oh my
god this is the guy we trusted
and then the fact that he says that
attacking him is attacking science so
now he's saying he's the definition of
science so then i
checked with my pals over at webster
dictionary and they actually define
science surprisingly falchi's name is
not in the definition
the state of knowing knowing uh
knowledge as distinguished from
ignorance or misunderstanding so then
here we go
with the misunderstanding thing again
which again marriage counseling
but i think personally i mean i guess we
misunderstood the fact that
masks do not protect us is that what we
misunderstood he's saying that it didn't
prove to be helpful outside of a
hospital setting right
so it's okay for doctors but it's not
okay for the rest of us like those in
the nursing home they're all dying
by the thousands and so therefore yeah i
mean less is more fouchy stop talking
that's true it's about time you know cat
if if somebody attacked cat timp they
would be attacking
oh god i'm not going to do that because
i'm not a psycho
like i will i'm only kind to psycho
right but like
this is you'd be attacking psychos no
because
i'm moderately hinged this is crazy
to say i am science that's like charlie
sheen circa 2011
crazy yes i am science
yes like i thought he was kind of like
dweeby maybe a little shady i was like
annoyed he's telling me i can't do stuff
i'm like
this man is completely insane that is
something a completely insane person
would say
and i like him even less because
normally when someone that is that
insane i find myself
attracted to them actually
to be clear i mean sexually but him
i don't crazy and not hot yeah
that's a tough combo
how do you get to work in these new york
city streets with the crazy people
i'm surprised she doesn't sleep with
like 10 people on the commute
not anymore i'm married now all right
and i'm sure he's very happy to hear
this look i did a lot for the homeless i
did a lot for the homeless
she's a giver oh my god help me off hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else